gmos are organisms whose genetic
material has been modified to give it a
new property for instance to make a plan
more resistant to diseases draught or
pesticides also improve its nutritional
value but this doesn't go without
controversy the EU has one of the
tightest GM 0 regulations in the world
in contrast with the US for example up
until now GMOs for feed and food have
been authorized on a case-by-case basis
following a company's application if the
European Food Safety Agency gives it
thumbs up then the Commission makes a
proposal and the Member States decides
however if there is not enough support
to authorize or reject a new GM 0 then
it's the Commission who decides but
growing public concerns and differing
views between Pro and against GMOs
countries push the Commission to give
member states a greater say so what will
exactly change if this new proposal is
adopted by the council tapasee
deodorization European Arrest Gazzola
mom lop opposition recognition clevo coo
Lizzie tamam only possibility that the
unknown show love territoire which is a
sunday sergio a total is au niveau opium
pasa la is drove juste Ichigo reporting
justification odo gizelle Katie which is
a poor Laval us know european but the
devil is in the details as Member States
may fear that this freedom would in fact
be difficult to exercise the grounds
that it may contravene the rules of the
internal market and the e use
international trade commitments all
these questions will now be analyzed by
EU ministers and council experts to try
to reach a common position on the new
GMO rules
you